uh how was Japan good question it was
awesome it was awesome it was awesome
was awesome no it was good you know
Tokyo Fun City you
Tokyo you
too fun city all right Tokyo yeah nose
is grown in a
mile how was it shout out Beck thanks
for making our Personality yeah we've
actually never needed to be funny we
just copied back yeah yeah Tokyo is cool
it's uh you know beautiful city you feel
how American you are like when you speak
at your normal volume everyone is very
you know
yeah uh there's that and then I started
reading into other dark aspects like the
frequency of salary men just jumping
onto the train tracks yeah um and it was
it was crazy our our friend was going to
back to the airport she's like oh my
train is delayed for injury
oh and that's someone that jumped off
yeah in front of it yeah yeah that's
dark
yeah yeah I like how that they just say
that over the intercom and everyone has
to pretend yeah oh or just everyone's
like oh I
guess did you eat any good
food no I just how do we get to Suicide
so quickly there I just
yeah yeah
yeah had some amazing food went to this
pork KATU place where we served it like
highend sushi different cuts of pork oh
[__] yeah you got to eat it different
ways what talking about yeah yeah he get
he cut lays down the first piece and
it's got some juice on the top and he's
like suck it off first he told you to
suck his Pork yeah suck the pork suck
the juice off the pork yeah we ate John
pork we killed him we cut him up and ate
him you know John pork no who that dude
pull up John pork who's John pork that
name rules John pork John
pork you don't know about John pork no
is he a meme what's yeah John pork is
call yeah I love this yeah this is great
so many dude the AI of John pork him
just being like yeah the bucket head and
N wife
crazy but yeah he lays down this piece
and there's some juice on the top and he
goes suck it first and then a little
salt and then dip it you know so every
bite was you had instructions gotcha um
and because I got this fish allergy
which is so lame I've never needed to
have Wasabi really mhm I think I've had
like
Wasabi like flavored snacks and stuff
but nothing I can remember yeah but this
is the first time I
actually ate Wasabi cuz he served he
served us one and he just dollops it on
top and I go the pork with the pork nice
which I I thought was unconventional I
didn't know if that was like a normal
thing I mean you can eat wasabi on
anything yeah but I'm like here we
go and uh it was fresh yeah freshly
ground yeah that [__] is [__] awesome
did it hit you in your brain oh yeah
yeah isn't that crazy cuz he he goes
normal spicy [__] it's like you feel it
in your throat and your neck or like you
know your tongue or whatever
Wasabi just goes right here it's like
yeah so yeah that that went off the
ramen was nuts bu was it busting it was
busting had some crazy good beef nice um
yeah tried their McDonald's
mhm TW good yeah yeah different than
America uh I think I had it there too
but I forget I forget how it was
different because I feel
McDonald's is really good yeah yeah I
mean I love the McDonald's app
especially no I think McDonald's
everywhere besides America is really
good yeah here it's just it's also good
it's good here but it's not I don't know
I feel in other countries it's more
consistent I would say maybe a little
bit more consistent and and like higher
quality yeah wait speaking of food dude
I think we should hit this Tik Tok
before we finish because so many people
sent me this all right how you doing
boss man let me get everything bagel do
a half pound of poop hey uh the usual
for me quter quarter scoop poop on the
poop poop Bagel I'm going to do a bigle
everything scoop it out do a little
locks and you know throw a little poop
on there pepper ketchup poop toasted on
over easy has brown let me do a half a
pound of bacon egg and cheese with a
little bit of mayonnaise on the side and
then I don't know throw a little poop on
the top throw a little poop on the
top damn yeah that
that's that's everything we do right
there yeah let me get the 16inch
BLT with the thr it in the microwave
throw it in the microwave and maybe heat
it up a little bit you know what [__] it
let me get the Philly cheese I'll do the
Philly cheese yeah Philly poop steak
Yeah the Philly poop steak let me get
the
18in and uh yeah instead of mayonnaise
why don't you go just lather that up
with
poop yeah yeah uh yeah let me get the
18inch Philly sub mayonnaise for
poop got get the poop aoli on it too
please the evolution of ordering at the
poop Del can I do a plain bagel cream
cheese and put a little poop on it you
done I'm going to do an everything bagel
vegetable cream cheese and then do a
plop of poop right on top how you doing
man I'm going to do an everything bagel
locks cream cheese and then I'm going to
do a double poop scoop on top do the two
scoops of poop how you doing Mikey I'm
going to do a bacon egg and cheese and
do a shmear of poop not too much though
Joey what's the Hershey
squirt 8 lb of
poop yeah I'll try it what's up boss man
I'm going to do Italian bread chicken
cutlet lettuce tomato poop olive oil and
then do do a half pound of poop on the
side so I could dip you know dip the
sandwich in the poop get the sandwich in
the
poop what's this dude's name yeah shout
out this guy what's his name it's
Frank shout out it's Frankie this is
different from it's Frankie 12 yeah yeah
yeah it's not Frankie 12 yeah it's
Frankie Frank 13 Frankie if that is your
[__] athlete number please take that
[__] out of your [__] name man yeah
every just Brute Force like
go oh he's number 13 on the wrestling
team got it yeah exactly you're going to
get hack so that's that's in your
password all right in the bonus today
I'm going to eat some C straming or I'm
going to at least smell it some more or
we're going to open this can or we're
going to leave it there actually not
open it no that's the second can of Sir
straming oh there's another can you
think we just get one can there's a
brand new can in here yo I'll give you
$1,000 right now you cut a hole in that
put a straw in and just yeah
yeah o wait a
minute that's a little bit like
wet maybe that's what was smelling oh
that's like greasy what the [__] is on
there it
leaked definitely smells like
fish ooh now that's botulism right there
ooh now that is some botulism Now That's
What I Call botulism yeah let me get a
little botulism on the top yeah bacon
egg and cheese with some some
botulism okay I'm going to go wash my
hands I want to see the LA version of
The Poop
Deli
what hey hey how we doing uh yeah I'm
going to get the uh kale salad with
light on the nuts and just a Sprinkle of
poop in
there I didn't realize that the scooped
Bagel was a thing until that whole
Twitter cuz there was that guy who was
like I went to this Deli and I asked for
a scoop Bagel he didn't know what I was
talking bagel
yeah someone was like I couldn't believe
what a scooped Bagel was until like I
looked it up or couldn't believe it when
I looked it up like I don't know Bagel
shell yeah why the [__] would you get
that I don't know man I'm going to wash
my hands
bye